after several delays Shazam Fury of the
Gods is almost here and fans are hyped
here's what you and your family need to
know before the big premiere
Shazam Fury of the Gods has been in the
production pipeline for quite some time
the sequel was announced in April 2019
right after the first film hit theaters
of course we've been waiting for quite a
while since then what possibly could
have delayed the development of Shazam 2
well possibly a pandemic that shuttered
an entire industry and a massive company
merger and a complete restructuring of
the DC Universe you know a few minor
things here and there originally the
movie was supposed to hit theaters on
April 1st 2022. but hey April fools the
film was then pushed back to November
4th 2022 before getting shuffled off to
June 2nd 2023 followed by a new date of
December 16 2022 not wanting to compete
against the blue-skinned Juggernaut that
is Avatar the way of water Warner
Brothers push Fury of the Gods back yet
again kicking it over to December 21st
the sequel was eventually moved yet
again to its hopefully final release
date of March 17
2023. granted it is enough to give a DC
fan some serious Whiplash but we're
pretty sure it will be worth the wait
when the Shazam Lee soars into theaters
in the first Shazam film we watched a
young Billy Batson adopt his new
superhero Persona and battle the evil
Duggar Savannah all while coming to
terms with his troubled past and finding
Solace with his new Foster family now
Billy and his siblings are out in the
world fighting crime with the powers of
literal Gods naturally Billy's got a lot
to learn about his new abilities and
also needs to deal with something of an
existential crisis but things get a lot
more complicated with the arrival of
three Greek goddesses the daughters of
Atlas are coming to hunt us
according to the official plot synopsis
they're on the hunt for the magic stolen
from them long ago that magic just so
happens to give the Shazam Lee their
powers based on the official trailers it
looks like the goddesses will try to get
their hands on a scepter that looks an
awful lot like the one belonging to the
wizard who granted Billy his powers it
also appears that scepter will give them
the ability to steal the Shazam Lee's
superhero abilities and it doesn't help
matters any that two of the daughters
espera and Calypso are bringing along a
whole bunch of monsters to wage war on
the world interestingly when it comes to
comic book accuracy the daughters of
Atlas are a bit of a mixed bag Atlas
himself is a DC Comics character
although we don't know if he'll be
appearing in the movie and so is Athena
who's more closely aligned with Wonder
Woman on the page however Aspera and
Calypso while hailing from Greek
mythology are new to the DC Mythos
having never appeared in comic book form
before it'll be interesting to see how
these goddesses play out in the story
although we're guessing Athena will
eventually shift sights while the
sisters will be pretty solidly bad guys
there's no Shazam without Zachary Levi
the adult version of the titular hero is
perhaps the funniest superhero in cinema
and that's thanks to Levi's natural wit
and charms fortunately Levi will be once
again donning the big red suit and
accompanying his teenage Alter Ego Asha
Angel as Billy Batson in the upcoming
movie you want these powers
for the Greek goddesses don't be
portrayed by Titans of Hollywood the
villainous Aspera will be played by the
legendary Helen Mirren her sister
Calypso will be portrayed by the one and
only Lucy Liu the third goddess is
Athena and she'll be played by Rachel
zegler who made a huge Hollywood Splash
with her debut performances Maria and
Steven Spielberg's West Side Story
character actor extraordinaire jaimon
hansu will return as a wizard who gave
Billy his superhero Powers while Marta
Milan's and Cooper Andrews will return
as Billy's loving foster parents
David F Sandberg broke onto the scene
with one of the creepiest short films
ever made 2013's lights out he then
turned that Eerie little film into a
feature-length movie released in 2016.
after that he Revisited the horror genre
with Annabelle creation before lending
his talents to the original Shazam now
Sandberg is back in the director's chair
for Shazam Fury of the Gods speaking
with total film the filmmaker explained
the movie would be taking a wider
approach to the story and his
character's on the first film saying
it's still shazam's movie but it's also
about the family they've all been
superheroes for a while now trying to
stop crime and save people but they're
not very good at it the city is dubbed
in the Philly fiascos the original
Shazam had pretty much everything
laughter tears screams and explosions
all that goodness was largely thanks to
screenwriter Henry Gayden who's also
worked on projects like Earth to Echo
and there's someone inside your house
never fear Gaiden is returning for part
two but he won't be working solo does
time around Gaiden is joined by Chris
Morgan which seems to indicate that Fury
of the guards will have a lot more
action how so well Morgan has penned the
scripts for multiple entries in the Fast
and Furious franchise including Tokyo
Drift Fast 5 Furious 7 and Hobbs and
Shore
but there's a lot changing in the world
of DC with James Gunn and Peter saffron
in charge the entire universe is getting
something of a reboot with some
superhero movies being canceled and new
ones on the way so where does the Shazam
series fit into gun and saffron's plans
for the future a lot has changed in the
last few years
while we don't know for sure for getting
a Shazam 3 Zachary Levi has commented on
the situation that's covered by The
Hollywood Reporter Levi took to
Instagram in December 2022 defending the
two new DC heads and asking fans to be a
little more open to their new Direction
he also gave an update on his own status
saying I have no idea what's ultimately
going to happen to me I think I'm in a
pretty good position I think we made a
pretty great movie and I think it's
going to do reasonably well I hope so
but again regardless of that if they
decide at some point to recast me the
mems the brakes that's how it goes that
same month a distress fan on Twitter
responded to a rumor that Levi would no
longer be Shazam saying they would throw
hands to protect the Levi's place in the
DC Universe the Tweet caught Levi's
attention and the Shazam actor gave this
response oh I really wouldn't go
believing everything you see on the
internet I'm Gucci we all Gucci
hopefully we'll figure out soon enough
what gun and saffron have in store for
our literal man child superhero
[Music]